vamos a recordar un poco lo que ya
sabemos acerca de los orbitales solo
algunas cosas que ya vimos en la lista
de química y bueno digamos que está por
aquí el núcleo de nuestro átomo que es
una cosa así súper chiquita y alrededor
de él tenemos a nuestro orbital ese uno
que podemos pensarlo como una nube vamos
a escribirlo por aquí tenemos en nuestro
orbital 1s y en este orbital caben dos
electrones entonces el primer electrón
de cualquier átomo siempre está en el
orbital ese uno y también podemos tener
otro electrón en el orbital ese uno por
ejemplo el hidrógeno tiene un solo
electrón que tiene que estar en la
órbita de uno y otro ejemplo es el helio
que tiene dos electrones y los dos están
en la órbita de ese uno y sólo hasta que
ya llenamos la órbita de ese uno es que
los electrones empiezan a estar en la
órbita 2s ok vamos a poner por aquí la
órbita 2s tenemos que pensar en esta
órbita
s 2 como la cáscara de la órbita s 1 y
en realidad no podemos pensar en estas
órbitas como cosas sólidas en realidad
tenemos que pensar en ellas como nubes
de probabilidad o sea todos los puntitos
en los cuales es probable que se
encuentre el electrón entonces el
orbital s 2 es como una cáscara de nube
alrededor del orbital s 1 y el siguiente
electrón de este átomo va en este
orbital al igual que el cuarto electrón
de este átomo
ahora estoy poniendo una flecha hacia
arriba y otra flecha hacia abajo
en estos dos orbitales porque un
electrón gira hacia un lado y el otro
electrón gira en la dirección opuesta
juncker y ya la forma en que giran le
llamamos spin que viene de la palabra
spin giro en inglés y eso pasa en todos
los orbitales siempre tenemos un
electrón girando en un sentido con
cierto espín y otro electrón girando en
el sentido contrario con el espín
opuesto
ahora si seguimos agregando electrones
va a empezar a utilizar las órbitas 2p
hay tres de estas órbitas 2p y en cada
una de ellas pueden estar a lo más dos
electrones entonces en total en las
órbitas 2p caben seis electrones pero
bueno vamos a necesitar poner estas
órbitas más pequeñas y dibujar los ejes
x jay-z aunque hay recuerda que este es
un dibujo tridimensional este es el eje
x eje x para adelante y para atrás luego
por aquí tenemos el eje y para adelante
y para atrás piensa que este es un plano
que estamos viendo desde arriba y
finalmente el eje z eje z aunque y este
es el eje y bueno podríamos decir que
los orbitales 2 t están alargados a lo
largo de cada uno de estos ejes aunque
hay por ejemplo hay un orbital al que le
llamamos
p x porque corre a lo largo del eje x en
una forma de mancuerna una forma más o
menos así que bueno en realidad estas
dos hojas son simétricas pero trate de
hacer esta más grande para que como que
resaltará en el dibujo y bueno recuerda
que son nubes de probabilidades y
también tenemos un orbital 2p que corre
a lo largo del eje y que también es una
nube de probabilidad que representa la
probabilidad de que un electrón esté en
ese punto como corre a lo largo del eje
y le llamamos el orbital
2b jeff y también tenemos un orbital
llamado 2 p z porque tiene una forma de
mancuerna alargándose en el eje z y
entonces si seguimos agregando
electrones osea si ponemos un quinto
electrón ese electrón va a ir a la
órbita 2 px un electrón en la órbita 2
px
ahora si agregamos otro electrón ese
electrón no se va a poner en la órbita 2
px se va a poner en la órbita 2p y ok
porque los electrones quien están
separados del resto de los electrones
entonces el sexto electrón se va a la
órbita 2 pero si agregamos otro electrón
este nuevo electrón no se va ni a la
órbita 2 px ni a la órbita 2 p y este
electrón se va a la órbita 2 pz
y finalmente si agregamos un octavo
electrón entonces ahora si ya se mete a
la órbita 2 px pero con el espín
contrario al electrón que ya está en la
órbita 2 px
y bueno si seguimos agregando electrones
ahora sí se van a llenar estas otras dos
órbitas entonces este fue un pequeño
repaso con un poco de visualización
ahora tomando en cuenta lo que acabamos
de ver pensemos en qué es lo que le
sucede a los átomos de carbono
bono que tiene como un número atómico 6
o sea que tiene 6 electrones electrones
y su configuración electrónica es 1 s al
cuadrado luego 2 s al cuadrado y luego 2
t al cuadrado ok esto lo que significa
es que tenemos la órbita 1s y hay 2
electrones en la órbita 1 s luego
tenemos la órbita 2 cc y pues si
agregamos otros 2 electrones esos tienen
que ir a la órbita 2 cc y finalmente
pues como tenemos 6 electrones y ya
tenemos 4 electrones en las órbitas 1s y
2 cc pues tiene que haber dos electrones
en alguna órbita 2 p no necesariamente
la misma como estábamos viendo por aquí
y como vamos a necesitar más espacio
vamos a hacer todo esto más chiquito y
vamos a poner por aquí los orbitales del
carbono tenemos porque el 1 s
el 2
el 2 de x 2 p y 2 de zeta
y entonces siguiendo la configuración
electrónica del carbono sabemos que aquí
tiene que haber un electrón luego el
segundo electrón va también aquí en la
órbita 1 s el tercer electrón por aquí
en la órbita 12 s al igual que el cuarto
electrón y después tenemos 2 electrones
en la órbita 2 p entonces el quinto
electrón va en la órbita 2 px que bueno
en realidad pudo haber sido la órbita 2
pero la órbita 2 pz todo depende de cómo
le llamemos a nuestros ejes y el sexto
electrón va en cualquiera de las otras
dos órbitas 2 p aunque entonces vamos a
decir que está en la órbita 2 belle y de
hecho si lo dibujamos nos queda algo
como esto aquí está el eje de las equis
aquí está el eje de las leyes y por aquí
está el eje de las zetas
y entonces nuestro núcleo de estado como
por aquí y la órbita 1s está más o menos
aquí toda esta nube es la órbita 1s y
tenemos dos electrones podríamos decir
que están saltando o moviéndose con
giros opuestos en esta nube alrededor
del núcleo que es la órbita 1s luego
tenemos la órbita 2s que es otra nube
pero en forma de cáscara alrededor de la
órbita 1s y en esta órbita tenemos
también los electrones girando en
direcciones opuestas luego tenemos la
órbita dos px que es esta órbita en
forma de mancuernas por aquí y aquí
tenemos únicamente un electrón y
finalmente tenemos la órbita
2b y que es esta otra órbita la órbita
2p y en la cual está saltando por ahí
únicamente un electrón y bueno
basándonos en esto de aquí pues vemos
que nada más aquí hay dos electrones
que como que están muy sólidos porque no
tienen a otro electrón que esté girando
en la dirección opuesta y entonces estos
dos electrones o sea estas dos órbitas
son los lugares en los que nosotros
podríamos creer que el carbono hace sus
enlaces aunque si nos quedamos con este
modelo únicamente nosotros podríamos
pensar que el carbono sólo hace dos
enlaces y lo hace con estos electrones
que están saltando en las órbitas 2 px y
2 p y sin embargo el carbono es un
poquito más complejo y sus electrones no
se quedan estrictamente con esta
configuración cuando hacen un enlace con
otro átomo por ejemplo el metano es un
carbono que hizo un enlace con cuatro
hidrógenos y si el carbono siempre
tuviera esta configuración entonces
podríamos pensar que hace únicamente dos
enlaces en lugar de cuatro
ok porque aquí tenemos únicamente dos
electrones que están solitos buscando
alguna pareja algún otro electrón que
gire en el sentido contrario y esos son
los electrones que forman los enlaces
los que están solitos entonces si los
electrones del carbono siempre tuvieran
esta configuración el carbono solo
podría tener dos enlaces y sabemos que
no es así el carbono siempre hace cuatro
enlaces monkey porque al carbono le
gusta pretender que tiene ocho
electrones bueno de hecho a todos los
átomos les gustaría pretender que tienen
ocho electrones y para hacer esto me
pretender que tienen otro electrones los
átomos cambian la configuración en la
que están sus electrones en las órbitas
para poder formar más enlaces y de esa
forma poder pretender que los electrones
del otro átomo son parte de sus
electrones y así pretender que tiene 8
electrones entonces está configuración
de los electrones del carbono no sucede
no sucede cuando el carbono hace enlaces
cuando el carbono hace así enlaces
es lo que realmente sucede cuando el
carbono hace enlaces y bueno esto nos va
a llevar a discutir las órbitas híbridas
sp3 pero pues vas a ver que son mucho
más sencillos que es un nombre lo que
realmente sucede con el carbono es que
sus órbitas se ven así a ver tenemos el
1s el 2 s el 2 p x2 de james y 2 de 7
y el primer electrón está en la órbita 1
es el segundo electrón está en la órbita
1 s sabemos que tiene 6 electrones y que
el carbono hace 4 enlaces nunca y eso lo
que significa es que tiene 4 electrones
saltando libremente en alguna órbita y
además solito sin algún otro electrón
con su spin contrario en esa misma
órbita y esos 4 electrones solitos están
dispuestos a involucrarse con algún
electrón de otra molécula y así formar
un enlace con esa molécula aunque en el
caso del metano esa otra molécula es un
átomo de hidrógeno lo que nos podemos
imaginar es que llega un átomo de
hidrógeno y jala a este electrón bueno a
este electrón de aquí llega y lo atrae y
lo jala a un mayor estado de energía y
lo jala hasta acá a la órbita 2 pz
ok entonces el electrón no aparece por
aquí en la órbita 2 pz y estos dos
electrones están por aquí y ahora si
tenemos 4 electrones libres para formar
enlaces ahora es un poco arbitrario esto
de cuál electrón cae en cuál de las
órbitas y con este modelo todavía
estamos sugiriendo que estos enlaces
suceden pues en estas órbitas que
dibujamos por aquí cuando en realidad
estos electrones no se van a quedar en
tal cual en estas órbitas que dibujamos
por aquí ok si van a tener su órbita
pero no va a ser como la que dibujamos
aquí aunque este electrón no se va a
quedar en la órbita 2
es en este electrón no se va a quedar en
la órbita 2 px y no va a pasar lo mismo
con estos dos sino que más bien se va a
formar como que una mezcla entre estas
cuatro órbitas aunque hay cada uno de
estos electrones para pasar una cuarta
parte del tiempo en la órbita dos cc y
las otras tres cuartas partes del tiempo
en una órbita que se parece a una del
tipo 2 p aunque entonces este electrón
no va a estar en la órbita 2 cc sino en
una órbita a la que le vamos a llamar 2
excepto ok y lo mismo pasa con todos
estos electrones
pasan 25 del tiempo en una órbita ese y
75% del tiempo en una órbita del tipo p
aunque pero aquí me faltó ponerle el 3 a
todas estas órbitas porque tenemos una
órbita del tipo 12 y tres órbitas del
tipo 2 p ok entonces cuando se combinan
estas cuatro órbitas se forman cuatro
órbitas de la forma 2
s&p cúbica a ver y ahora si queremos
dibujarlo vamos a hacerlo por aquí una
órbita 12 ese es de esta forma como una
nube en forma de cáscara alrededor del
núcleo y una órbita 2p es de esta forma
más o menos que es la órbita 2s y esta
es la órbita 2p y cuando estas dos
órbitas se mezclen para formar la órbita
12 sp3 lo que nos queda es una órbita de
esta forma aunque esta es una órbita 2
s&p kubica aunque es la órbita híbrida y
12 esp 3 aunque muchas veces nos
olvidamos de este 2 todos estos
orbitales y le llamamos simplemente la
órbita híbrida sp3 ahora que nos
referimos con híbrida pues las cosas
híbridas son las cosas que son
combinaciones de dos cosas por ejemplo
los coches híbridos lo que usan es gas y
electricidad en este caso tenemos dos
tipos de órbitas y los combinamos y se
forme la órbita híbrida sp3
y estas son las órbitas en los que se
mueven los electrones del carbono con el
carbono hace enlaces con otras moléculas
como el hidrógeno y entonces cuando
dicen que el carbono tienen órbitas
híbridas sp3 cuando hace enlaces con
cuatro hidrógenos para formar el metano
a lo que se refiere es que tiene cuatro
de estas órbitas que son una combinación
de una órbita ese y tres órbitas presse
entonces pues vamos a dibujarlo más
abajo
por ejemplo digamos que tenemos por aquí
el carbono y pues como estamos viendo
tiene cuatro órbitas sp3 aunque entonces
tienen por aquí un globito saliendo por
aquí y del otro lado tiene un globito
pero mucho más chiquito aunque hay
porque si son las órbitas híbridas sp3
después tiene otra órbita por aquí pero
piensa que estamos en la segunda
dimensión y bueno aquí esto no me va a
salir muy bien dibujado pero tiene una
órbita que está detrás de estas dos
órbitas aunque piénsalo así como que
tenemos un tripié que está detrás de
esta órbita
pero pues en realidad esta parte está
detrás de la órbita azul y lo mismo esta
parte está detrás de la órbita verde y
finalmente tenemos otra órbita por aquí
que sale hacia arriba ok si no le
ponemos volumen en las órbitas y los
pensamos nada más con palitos tenemos
aquí el carbono el núcleo del carbono y
luego tenemos una órbita que está yendo
hacia adelante hacia acá luego tenemos
otra órbita que está yendo hacia
adelante hacia acá y otra órbita que
está yendo hacia atrás directamente
hacia atrás entonces tenemos aquí un
tripié claramente y una órbita que está
yendo ni hacia adelante ni hacia atrás
simplemente hacia arriba aunque es tal
cual un triple ok entonces este es
nuestro carbono no esto carbono y si
vamos a construir una molécula de metano
este carbono va a ser enlaces con cuatro
hidrógenos entonces por aquí está un
hidrógeno que tiene únicamente uno
en su órbita 1s y esa órbita se ve así
tal cual por aquí tiene otro hidrógeno y
otro hidrógeno y otro hidrógeno la
verdad aquí es que estas patas del
triple deberían de haber quedado mucho
más abiertas aunque entonces esto es una
molécula de metano que es ch4 gray y
allí esta órbita 1s está haciendo un
enlace con esta órbita sp3 entonces si
nos quedáramos con el modelo en el cual
no estamos considerando que se forman
estas órbitas híbridas pues nosotros
podríamos pensar por aquí que tenemos un
hidrógeno por acá o un hidrógeno por acá
o por acá que si te fijas pues estas
moléculas forman una estructura
completamente distinta a la estructura
que teníamos por aquí con el tripié
cierto o sea esta estructura si lo
ponemos los hidrógenos por aquí tiene
forma de tetraedro
que si se apega a la realidad de cómo se
comporta el carbono cuando hace enlaces
con otras moléculas
aunque el carbono cuando hace enlaces
con los hidrógenos y con otras cosas
tiene una forma de tetraedro
pero no cree yo sea una forma como un
tripié y eso tiene sentido si tenemos
cuatro órbitas del mismo tipo que estas
órbitas unos híbridos entre la órbita s
y la órbita p bueno y otra cosa de
notación que es importante aquí es que
este tipo de enlace es un enlace sigma
enlace
en la cima de la letra griega sigma ok
ahora cómo se forman los enlaces sigma
puedes pues pensar aquí está el núcleo y
aquí está el núcleo y entonces esta
órbita podríamos pensar que está
apuntando en esta dirección y esta
órbita como es circular podríamos pensar
que está apuntando en todas las
direcciones incluso en esta dirección y
si tenemos dos órbitas que están
apuntando la una hacia la otra y se
intersectan esas dos órbitas como en
este pedazo entonces decimos que tenemos
un enlace sigma otra forma de verlo es
que tenemos por aquí dos núcleos los
conectamos por una línea y si la
intersección de las dos órbitas está en
medio de la línea que une a los dos
núcleos entonces también decimos que
tenemos un enlace sigma y
este enlace es el enlace más fuerte de
los enlaces covalentes y me parece que
este va a ser un buen tema de discusión
para el próximo vídeo cuando empiece a
hablar acerca de los enlaces pi pero
mientras tanto el meollo del asunto en
este vídeo es hablar acerca de las
órbitas sp3 y bueno ya vimos que las
órbitas sp3 son simplemente la
combinación de una órbita
efe con una órbita para los electrones
que están en una órbita sp3 lo que hacen
es pasar el 25% de su tiempo en una
órbita
efe y el 75% de su tiempo en una órbita
del tipo p y resulta que el ángulo entre
cada una de estas órbitas es de 109
puntos 5 ok aquí no lo dibujé muy bien
pero de este lado si lo dibujé muy bien
el ángulo entre todas estas patitas que
son las órbitas del carbono
todos estos ángulos
estoy ángulo entre esta órbita y esta
órbita y también con esta órbita y este
ángulo también y el ángulo que está más
difícil de dibujar por el ángulo entre
esta órbita y la órbita naranja también
son ángulos exactamente iguales y miden
ciento 9.5 grados y por eso es que la
molécula de metano tiene una forma de
tetra ebro porque las órbitas del
carbono se combinan para formar cuatro
órbitas igualitas llamadas órbitas
híbridas sp3